a lot of modern cars come with advanced
driver assistance systems things like
adaptive cruise control that keeps a
safe distance from the car in front or
automated emergency braking to avoid
collisions or Lane Assist
to keep you in Lane which is great as
long as the driver knows the system's
limits the worst modern car I've ever
driven came with adaptive cruise control
that turned itself off if you went under
20 miles an hour
so if the car in front slowed down for a
traffic jam so would you until you went
under 20 at which point the car just
handed control off to you with a very
quiet beep and if you weren't expecting
that this is the global vehicle target
and as of this year it is part of the
Euro endcap standard on how to test the
safety of automated driving systems but
it isn't just a static phone model this
base here is a robot platform that goes
up to 50 miles an hour which means you
can test safely with both vehicles going
at highway speed right my turn in the
passenger seat I mean the real car not
this this doesn't have a passenger seat
fashion research is a not for profit
insurance funded research center in
about 2014 it became clear that the next
generation of technologies weren't just
going to look for the rear end of the
car that we're going to look at the side
of the car and even the front of a car
we've got to have a target that actually
looks like a three-dimensional car the
impact of a bit the visual pieces of the
car are actually foam target blocks that
are assembled to look like a car and
covered with the radar material
generally you can put the target from
start back together in about 15 to 20
minutes but what we've done is we've
used test equipment that actually
measures the radar reflectivity of a
real vehicle you get radar reflectivity
of a wheel and even the glass the back
of a vehicle has a certain radar
signature so it's about putting radar
reflectors have also radar absorbent
material in the right place so the
brand-new test that we're going to
introduce in 2020 are what we call turn
across paths where your vehicle is
moving in front of another vehicle and
we want your vehicle to break we're also
developing Junction tests where a
vehicle moves across your path laterally
and therefore we need to see the side of
the vehicle and we're confident that if
a vehicle breaks for our target it will
break for a real vehicle in the real
world this should stop in time yes okay
all right let's do it first of all that
works oh that made me feel so nervous
it's deliberately late enough radars a
very good understanding if something is
moving they can identify what it is
however if you just come across an
object and it's stationary it's much
harder for the radar to identify that
that's a vehicle
what's the difficulties understanding
has the driver seen it and what are the
driver intentions so if you've got a
vehicle that's parked in front of you it
doesn't want to warn you too early
because that's going to annoy the driver
we don't want that because if your
driver is annoyed
it will turn the system off one of the
problems vehicle manufactures have is
there not only differences in the road
infrastructure there's actually national
characteristics people in Germany would
tend to drive slightly more aggressively
and therefore those who have false
positives it's much more of an issue
whereas the Swedes will tell you that
they're much more benign and therefore a
vehicle that's just stationary warning
the driver won't really annoy him too
much okay so what happens if we go
slightly faster well right
like this I really don't like this Oh
[Music]
does it slightly break to warn you
yes yes you hope is that little weight
is enough for the drive to go oh this is
something changes happening
yeah themselves okay yeah that works
so is the Tongass yeah thank you very
much to all the team at Thatcher
research pull down the description for
more about them and their work